oh yeah
humans have been evolving for the past
six million years but something's gone
terribly wrong
now we're evolving backward
once this process began how long would
it take for you to become an ape again
what does climate have to do with it
and why would Society completely
collapse
this is what if and here's what would
happen if humans evolved backward
thanks to Evolution Humanity dominates
Earth but how did that happen
well first don't think of evolution as a
straight and narrow path
Evolution happens through the process of
natural selection over millions of years
organisms adapt to their environments by
developing the traits needed to keep
them alive
the life forms that don't adapt die
Evolution doesn't have an end goal for
you it's a never-ending process of
survival
so if you started devolving today how
soon would Humanity perish
you know climate and evolution go hand
in hand and with such extreme weather
hitting the Earth I'm looking at you
California it's hard to imagine what
changes the next few thousand years will
bring fortunately we have some good news
that hole in the ozone layer is healing
the void was first noticed in the 1980s
and it's expected to return to normal by
2045 but before celebrating know that
this didn't happen through good luck
that damaging hole is being repaired
thanks to Decades of environmental
regulations and legislation like the
inflation reduction act and we're just
getting started by 2030 the IRA could
reduce carbon emissions by 40 percent
we're on the right path so keep up the
good work and stay focused our Evolution
and future as a species are in your
hands
your journey through Devolution would
eventually take you into the microscopic
Realm
should take billions of years for you to
get there but for the sake of our
scenario we're going to speed this
process up like way up
like let's say you raced through the
backward Evolution at the speed of one
million years in one day
well before you shrunk out of sight your
body would stretch to new heights well
that's good news for my short Kings out
there
in just one hour you would grow to
around 1.8 meters tall your jaw and
teeth would also expand and your brain
size would increase massively
yeah that melon of yours is getting huge
you just devolved back into Homo erectus
Humanity's long extinct cousin
and these changes would have major
consequences on your life
another two minutes and you'd lose brain
capacity you'd forget how to hunt or
farm from now on your diet would be
limited you'd eat whatever you could
find in the wild or you could make a
trip to the grocery store while they
still exist but you certainly wouldn't
be smart enough to understand how to pay
clothes would be a thing of the past now
you'd be letting everything hang free
you'd forget everything you wouldn't
know how to bury the dead or how to
create art
you'd be naked hungry kind of dumb and a
little uglier
the good news well no one would tell you
after about four hours into this
experiment well you'd lose the ability
to talk and as you grunted your way
through life society around you would
start to crumble yeah in the next two
and a half days cities would become
abandoned ruins of a Time forgotten
instead of living in these buildings
you'd prefer roughing it in huts
now you would devolve into Homo habilis
eating leaves plants and whatever animal
you could catch
with your diminished brain capacity you
wouldn't be able to use stone tools
anymore and a warm fire would be a rare
luxury
after six days you'd devolve back into a
chimp you'd be living off The Spoils of
the Jungle eating seeds nuts and insects
over the next couple of months wild
primates would rain on Earth again
okay after six months of your Devolution
the lines between species would blur
now you would live among the monotreams
mammals that lay eggs like the Platypus
yeah you'd be hatched into this new
world
after one year you'd be wallowing in
freshwater habitats with the other
tetrapods and if that sounds refreshing
well just wait in one more year you'd
live it up as a starfish or a worm-like
creature floating in the ocean without
care
the once great species known as humans
would return to a single-celled bacteria
10 years into this wild experiment
all of human history your knowledge and
experiences would be gone and you would
be reduced to a tiny Speck
so once you're back in this simple State
could you evolve back into a human again
yeah well probably not
we humans evolved this way thanks to a
lot of luck and specific circumstances
it all depends on the new conditions on
our planet
you could develop blue skin like the
navi or even become bioluminescent
wow
maybe you would just be a pile of slime
who knows
listen Devolution is a fun Theory but
it's unlikely to happen like this
the situations that made your ancestors
Branch out from other species don't
exist to make this process happen in
exact reverse order
it's not like pressing rewind
but what if you could fast forward and
evolve 1 000 years in one day
well be a good monkey and stay right
here because that's a story
for another
what if